Fort Collins Colorado starts off this
hour Courtney is with us hey Courtney
what's up thank you so much for taking
my call Dave first of all we are a
little bit of a predicament we were in
the middle of baby step one when my
husband was in a car accident that
totaled a police vehicle that I had so
we're dealing with all that and we know
we now have to replace that vehicle our
biggest issue is that my husband is
pretty much a road work warriors for
worse so we put about forty to fifty
thousand miles a year on a car with
about a thousand miles
oh.he and we're just trying to figure
out you know you're going to tell me not
to take a loan we're trying to figure
out our best option on how to get
something that's going to be semi
reliable for the interim right okay I
assume that the car lease is basically
going to be paid from insurance and
you're not going to get any net proceeds
into your pocket right actually going to
be about a thousand to fifteen hundred
dollars upside down in it okay all right
so you got at least got out of that mess
okay yeah and if then that leaves you
with no money and no car right exactly
and your household income is what it's
about seventy five thousand a year it
just increased to that cool and what is
the car that you are driving the car
that I thought we I'm currently driving
her the car that was totaled no the one
that you drive that was his car that was
totaled well it was my father he was
driving that with Soto oh okay then
what's the other car the other car is a
2004 Dodge Ram 3500 and that's not a his
vehicle but since he's got this new job
and started commuting we didn't want a
million miles on that gotcha okay well
that's a good good thought well there's
a couple things run through my head when
you tell me your story and then we just
got to figure out how to solve it from
here the lease was how much what was the
balance on that that the insurance
company is going to write the check for
well the balance on the lease was about
c600 and the insurance company is going
to be writing a check for about four
grand okay that's not the payoff on the
car that was just the remaining number
of payments payoff on the car was fifty
six hundred really you could have owned
the car title for that so you there was
a cheap car that was leased i it was and
i was stupid when i bought it alright
let's let's back up then i didn't it's
not it doesn't really change anything
but it's just an interesting factoid
okay so here two things to know number
one and you probably heard me say this
before when you're a road warrior
whatever you're driving you are
destroying it whatever he's driving he's
destroying its value mmm-hmm whatever
you drive if you drive a hundred
thousand dollar car if you drive a two
thousand dollar car you destroy its
value fifty thousand miles a year yeah
it's gonna be worth nothing fast so the
trick is to destroy the cheapest car
possible that will get the job done now
getting the job done in my mind is two
things one is to be reasonably
comfortable this guy lives in his car
we're not putting him in a smart car
okay I mean you've been a chiropractor
right so we're gonna put him in a decent
vehicle that's got a little legroom and
a little metal around him and that kind
of stuff the second thing is it has to
be reliable because he can't be out
there broke down on the South Road and
get his job done exactly and so has to
be the that's what I mean when I say the
least car that will get the job done
that's usually an eight or a ten
thousand dollar car and you're gonna buy
it differently and you're gonna buy a
new one a change you're gonna not a new
one you're gonna sell that one and get a
different ten thousand dollar car once a
year mm-hmm and just drive put fifty
thousand miles on it and do it again and
it could be like a nice little Ford
Taurus a Honda Accord a little SUV the
smaller versions those kinds of things I
don't care but something that's just
very bland you know a Toyota Camry that
kind of a thing that's got a lot of life
left in it and you're gonna take most of
its life and then you're gonna roll it
every 12 to 18 months
now so how we gonna get that eight or
ten grand well you were about eight or
ten grand in debt already on cars if you
go get a car to loan for eight or ten
thousand dollars put that in your debt
snowball you know you're basically
saying I had a car loan eight or ten
thousand dollars and now I'm gonna have
a car loan eight or ten thousand dollars
this is a net you know we're not going
to use the fact that we this car got
totaled to go buy a twenty-five thousand
dollar car we're going to use the fact
that about a five or ten thousand dollar
car got totaled we're going to buy five
or a ten thousand dollar car so we're
not going further in debt because I
think the numbers you're giving me are
not the actual payoff of the lease
because that car is more expensive than
that you totaled then it's not a five
thousand dollar car the market value on
that car was considerably higher than
that so there's some number twist up and
what's going on with the insurance
company I don't care about that I'm
gonna set that to the side I'm gonna
call this about an even trade for you
eight or ten thousand dollars worth of
debt for eight or ten thousand dollars
worth of debt okay put it in your debt
snowball and get rid of it as fast as
you can now this is not you had a
thousand dollar car and you only needed
a thousand dollar car to commute two
miles to work and you went ten thousand
dollars in debt to get you a nicer car
that is not what this is this is an even
swap for a road warrior to get his job
done awesome you hear me not giving up
right where you don't want to move up we
just we the payments that I had on this
previous car I was I was taking really
bad and didn't read the fine print and I
was paying four hundred and twenty four
dollars a month for a 2003 Nissan Murano
Wow because I would so this is this is a
blessing because if he had run that car
out with that lease with those miles on
it he wouldn't run his miles up out of
elite you were to run your mouths up out
of that lease and you'd have been
surcharged out your ears
yeah for being over on your miles when
you turned it in so this has turned into
a huge blessing really I'm glad no one
was hurt and that way we can just call
it a blessing so that's how I'm looking
at two things is whatever you drive
you're destroying and the second thing
is is we're going to do a break even a
neutral deal here
no new debt no extra debt no nicer
car but we're also not gonna try to put
a guy been doing 50,000 miles a year on
a $2,000 car and expect him to get home
on the weekend it ain't gonna work so I
mean you can do a hoopty around town but
a hoopty with 50,000 miles a year's not
gonna cut it so you're gonna be and I
really would never have more than about
a 15,000 hour car if you got two million
dollars in the bank and you're putting
fifty thousand miles a year on a car you
can have a nice one but has to be the
one sits in the driveway your weekend or
ever you know and you're always gonna
have a fifteen ten thousand dollar car
if you're worth five million dollars I
mean I would never if I was putting that
kind of miles on a car I put it put it
on a nice car because you're destroying
it you're destroying the value of it and
yes you can put miles on a car and they
survived that's not the question but
you're just taking a hundred thousand
dollar car and turn it into a ten
thousand dollar car in 20 minutes so you
just don't want to do that folks and
people do it on the road all the time
they do it in name a business and
rationalization and all this crap and
just don't fall for that folks hey
Courtney thank you for calling in I hope
that was helpful to you this is the Dave
Ramsey show